mi voglio raccontare una storia che è
cominciata un miliardo e 200 milioni di
anni fa cioè milioncino un piumino chino
meno è questa storia è un po una storia
d'amore
solo che gli amanti sono particolari
sono due buchi neri che per milioni e
milioni di anni hanno girato una donna
all'altro avvicinandosi pian pianino
milioni e milioni di anni sapete l'amore
anche dai buchi neri e un po di giri
solo concerto momento sono arrivati così
vicini che si sono scontrati e hanno
formato un singolo buco nero ed a tutto
questo si è generata una potentissima
onda gravitazionale che ha viaggiato nel
tempo e nello spazio per anni ed anni
per km finché lo scorso settembre è
arrivata qui sul pianeta terra e noi
l'abbiamo vista e dopo mesi e mesi e
mesi di analisi di statistiche e tutto
quello che volete e non si è dormito
tanto abbiamo annunciato al mondo intero
che abbiamo visto la prima honda
gravitazionale la storia realtà è finita
qua però scommetto che mi ha lasciato un
po di curiosità tipo ma sto qua di cosa
diavolo sta parlando
cosa sono sti onde gravitazionali
allora facciamo un po di storia visto
che dobbiamo tornare indietro a 100 anni
fa quando un certo personaggio che forse
avete sentito parlare si chiamava
einstein se non ricordo male ha scritto
un articolo su una cosa che ha chiamato
relatività e su cui ha detto un sacco di
cose pazzesche ha detto con gli orologi
che si muovono vanno piu lenti degli
orologi fermi che quando un oggetto in
movimento si contrae rispetto a quando
era fermo che lo spazio il tempo fanano
fra loro
noi siamo una cosa pazzesca e non si è
fermato qui perché dieci anni dopo anche
detto che ogni massa per turbo e lo
spazio che acer che circonda
e veramente pazzesco e come vi è già
stato detto l'anno dopo ha detto di
queste onde gravitazionali
ma cosa vuol dire che la massa in curva
lo spazio ma immaginate che lo spazio
c'è un tappeto elastico
se voi camminare sul tappeto elastico
dritto andate dritti e non avete nessun
problema ma se appoggiate una massa su
questo tappeto elastico il tappeto
elastico si deforma e voi siete
costretti a seguire questa curvatura
allora per esempio prendiamo il sole che
perturba il suo elastico e lasciamo
scorrere la terra sull'elastico che è
curvato cosa succede che la terra deve
seguire una curvatura un po come quando
se avete un vortice nell'acqua
dovete le navi seguono il vortice e non
riescono ad uscire adesso facciamo un
passettino più avanti
ok prendiamo masse che si muovono
sull'elastico allora se ne ma se si
muovono anche l'elastico stesso si muove
e questo cosa provoca che non solo
vicino all'elastico siamo mossi ma anche
lontano lasciate cadere un sasso
nell'acqua
cosa succede che si propagano delle onde
lontano ecco allora questo elastico che
si muove continuamente anche lontano
dalle masse queste sono le onde
gravitazionali
ok abbiamo capito cosa sono cosa fanno
ma è quando arrivò non ghana
gravitazionale sulla terra succede
quello che state vedendo nel filmato fa
paura
ma perché io 14 settembre questa cosa
non l'ho vista perchè voi non avete
visto il vostro vicino che faceva tutto
così ecco allora quando passo non da
gravitazionali è sostanzialmente le
distanze si comprimano e si allargano ma
salgono di molto poco stiamo parlando di
distanze inferiori al nucleo di un atomo
quelle cose che non si vedono ad occhio
nudo
allora come facciamo a vedere quando
passa un'onda gravitazionale negli anni
sessanta hanno sviluppato questi
rivelatori con delle barre di alluminio
sostanzialmente cercavano di vedere se
le basi si allungavano 1
l'idea era buona però non è che
funzionasse molto bene allora qualche
anno dopo anno costruito questi
cosiddetti interferometri cosa sono gli
interferometri ma sostanzialmente si
prendono i laser perché usano i laser è
sempre figo
allora cosa si fa si prende un raggio
laser e si spara lungo due direzioni
diverse
in asia per coloro la stessa distanza
quando ritornano al punto di origine
sostanzialmente si sommano e si
annullano e non si vede nulla ma se è
passata un'onda gravitazionale le
distanze che ha percorso i laser sono
diverse e quindi non si annullano più
come prima ma sostanzialmente si vede un
po di luce quindi vedendo questa luce si
può vedere l'onda ok abbiamo capito
senza mente cosa possiamo come possiamo
vedere se onde ma che ce ne facciamo
allora adesso il nostro amico fido che
qua dietro mi invita a fare un piccolo
gioco quando ve lo dirò sostanzialmente
vita per e te le orecchie per qualche
secondo
io alzerò la mia mano così almeno
potrete quando no ma se no potete
riaprire le vostre orecchie
siete pronti ed è capito ok 321 più
bravi
i bravissimi adesso facciamo il secondo
giochino perché il nostro amico piace
giocare adesso vico prete gli occhi e in
questo momento sarà una mia bocca a
dirvi quando potete riaprirli pronti tre
due uno via ecco rilassatevi da che ci
siamo pensate di essere tranquilli fuori
al parco ci sono gli uccellini c'è anche
una leggera brezza avete il vostro
fidanzato fidanzata che aveva portato un
pic nic
siete pronti mangiate ok potete via
preso gli occhi che cosa abbiamo fatto
con tutto questo
ma quando abbiamo sostanzialmente
tappato le orecchie
abbiamo un pò visto quello come vedevamo
un universo fino ad oggi cioè con la
luce con gli occhi
questo lo spettro visibile della luce
però come vedete ha dei buchi si chiama
aspetto di assorbimento perché perché
quando la luce per esempio la viva nella
nostra atmosfera sostanzialmente
incontra idrogeno elio azoto e tutto
quello che c'è all'idrogeno si riprende
un pezzo lelio se ne prende un altro
l'azoto un'altra ancora è restano i
buchi
facciamo un po un esempio è come dire
che spedito una lettera un vostro amico
e il postino me ne cancella qualche
parola ma stando voi leggete la lettera
per carità però qualche parola ve la
siete persa con la luce e la stessa cosa
le onde gravitazionali hanno delle buste
così così fisse ma fisse che nessun
postino ii 6 aprile ma c'è molto di più
voi quando avete usato solo gli occhi
potevate vedere un cretino sopra il
parco con la mano alzata ma quando mi
avete ascoltato forse forse qualcuno di
voi si è immaginato veramente di essere
in quel parco le onde gravitazionali
sono un nuovo messaggero che ci descriva
in universo ne abbiamo già parecchi la
luce visibile la lucina rossa i raggi
gamma e tutti ci danno delle idee nuove
idee diverse
quindi anche le onde gravitazionali sono
un po il nostro modo di sentire
l'universo non solo di vederlo quindi ci
danno qualcosa in più
veramente si i buchi neri per esempio
per la prima volta abbiamo veramente
sentito il suono dei buchi neri finora
non potevamo vederli perché appunto sono
né
niente può arrivare dal buco nero ma non
da gravitazionale prodotta dai buchi
neri si e ne abbiamo vista possiamo
fermarci qui potremmo ma potremmo anche
fare di più non abbiamo mica solo i
buchi neri nell'universo ci sono anche
le stelle a neutroni e le insegna a
neutroni sono oggetti veramente molto
più complicati di un buco nero
l'equazione di stato i processi che ci
sono dentro quindi semplicemente dalla
luce che ci arriva dall'esterno e
neutroni sappiamo parecchio ma non
sappiamo tutto possiamo sapere di più
con le onde gravitazionali che ci
arriveranno dai buchi nei dalle stelle a
neutroni quando ci arriveranno andiamo
ancora avanti perché no le supernove
grandi esplosioni pazzesche che accadono
nell'universo che producono luce
neutrini raggi gamma infrarossi e anche
un né gravitazionali un altro messaggero
in più che ci spiega effettivamente come
queste esplosioni possono avvenire e
ultimo ma non ultimo il big bang di cui
sappiamo poco molto poco
praticamente niente sappiamo del big
bang però dalle onde gravitazionali del
big bang
potremmo scoprire i primissimi istanti
di vita dell'universo quelli che ancora
non sappiamo quindi cosa facciamo
giochiamo adesso sì che possiamo
rilevare le onde gravitazionali possiamo
giocare con le onde gravitazionali
possiamo tornare indietro i processi che
ne hanno generate e possiamo scoprire un
po di più come nell'universo funziona
l'amore